hey guys i'm off the grid for august but
here's a generic intro to a clip we
wanted to show you
listen i don't care what's in hunter
biden's i mean hunter bind at that point
hunter bind literally could have had had
the corpses of children in his basement
i would not have cared right it's like
it's there's nothing
first of all it's hunter biden right
it's not it's like it's not joe biden
but
even if joe like even whatever scope of
joe biden's corruption is like if we
could just go down that rabbit hole
endlessly and and
understand that he's getting kickbacks
from hunter biden's deals in ukraine or
whatever else right or china
it is
infinitesimal
compared to the corruption we know trump
is involved in it's like it's like it's
like a firefly to the sun right i mean
like there's just it doesn't even it
doesn't even stack up against trump
university right trump university as a
story
is worse than anything that could be in
in hunter biden's laptop in my view
right
now that's not that doesn't answer the
people who say it's still completely
unfair
to not have looked at the laptop in a
timely way and to have shut down the you
know the new york post's twitter account
like that that's just a conspiracy
that's a left-wing conspiracy to deny
the presidency to donald trump
absolutely it was absolutely right but i
think it was warranted right and i'm and
again it's a coin toss as to whether or
not i'm sorry that particular piece i'm
really sorry i i was the one that said
we should move on but you've just said
something i really struggled with that
which is
the kids in the basement you no no [ __ ]
the kids in the basement
i'm interested in democracy
you're saying you are content
with the left-wing conspiracy to prevent
somebody being democratically re-elected
as president well no i'm conte well so
it's but the thing is it's just not
left-wing right so liz cheney is not
left-wing right liz cheney is doing
everything in her policy to prevent
somebody being democratic it's not like
no but there's nothing conspiracy it's
not it was a conspiracy out in the open
it does but it doesn't matter if it
doesn't matter what parts conspiracy
what parts out in the open i mean i
think it's like if people get together
and talk and talk about what should we
do about this phenomenon you know if
it's like if there was an asteroid
hurtling toward earth
and and we got in a room together with
all of our friends and had a
conversation about what we could do to
deflect its course right
is that a conspiracy you know like some
of that conversation would be in public
some of it would be in private
we have a massive problem we have an
existential threat right politically
speaking i consider trump an existential
threat to our democracy right now it's
not he's not going to destroy the world
very likely he destroyed democracy in
the process of protecting democracy but
that doesn't destroy no you are our
i'm not what i'm not suggesting at no
point was i suggesting we should stuff
ballots or
or actually break the machinery of
democracy but
the
all
political opinion is already being
just completely inundated with
misinformation bias takes half truths
and outright lies right like and or just
the amplification of bad or misleading
information based on you know the
algorithm right
um
so it's like it's already
just an abattoir
of opinion right and now the question
is you know what can you do with your
own biases and your own the the to to
get the outcome you think is actually
better not just for yourself personally
but for the world right so like i have
like it is i'm completely unconflicted
in
in
the claim
that a tr that is a first trump term was
bad and a second trump term would be bad
and
it literally doesn't matter what was
what what else was on the menu like
literally pick up pick a random american
better than trump in the in the oval
office like the the likelihood that
you're going to get someone who's worse
than trump
given what i consider that
is bad about trump is
i mean it's
it's on the order of one in a million
right like you're just not you're not
going to get you're not going to get
worse than trump if you pick it random
and you know hillary clinton for all of
her flaws
was not worse than trump joe biden
brought joe biden we could have known
joe biden was going to just be comatose
in office
not worse than trump right